So Leute, ach guck mal mein Manager ist am Start, Pog, hat Hetzner schon was geschrieben?
Lass mich grad mal gucken.
Weiß nicht ob ich am Wochenende stream sonn muss oder nicht, also ich meine ich streame
eh aber je nachdem was, nee anscheinend noch nicht.
Ja danke für den Sub, 26 Monate, Massive Fire IQ hier.
Platzt der Kopf fast, obei, der Code geht schon oder, der neue, egal, den neuen Code
den kriegt ihr dann am Wochenende wahrscheinlich.
Muss ich mal gucken, je nachdem ob wir uns, ja verraten wir erst am Wochenende, es gibt
einen neuen Code aber der ist noch nicht offiziell, also das müssen wir mal abwarten.
Wieso steht da bis zum 31.12, nee das ist Absicht, das war so, ich hab keinen Code
zumindest noch nicht offiziell für dieses Jahr, weil die müssen uns auch noch ein Tracking
Link schicken fällt mir gerade ein, weil ohne Track, also ich brauch den Tracking Link nicht,
aber ich könnt mir vorstellen, dass es denen mit Tracking Link lieber ist.
Leute soll ich euch mal was zum Keg W erzählen von der Arbeit, oh guck mal der Weihnachtskeg
Keg ist am Start, den lassen wir jetzt mal kurz, Tracking, ja hier guck da siehst du
doch Tracking, dass man sieht, dass sie sehen, dass es viele Leute einlöst, bestimmt alles
DSGVO konform ist nicht mein Problem, ja ich erzähl euch was lustiges, wir hatten vor
zwei Tagen, nee heute war es nicht, muss gestern gewesen sein, oder war das heute, weiß gar
nicht, ist auch egal, nee ich glaub es war gestern, wir hatten gestern, hab ich mitbekommen
von unserem Support, also was heißt Support, ich sag immer Support, das ist ja eigentlich
gar nicht der Support, da sind eigentlich die die 247 Monitoring Überwachung und sowas
machen, aber da rufen halt auch Leute an und ja deswegen sag ich immer Support, eigentlich
ist es nicht Support, eigentlich ist es eher, wie heißt denn sowas, Operations Center oder
sowas, keine Ahnung wie man sowas nennt, so Leute die halt Schichtarbeiten 247 da sind
und gucken wenn was ausfällt, das dann eskalieren dann die richtigen Leute, zumindest es kam,
ich versteh mich mit denen ja recht gut, ich krieg da auch so die Sachen mit, es kam gestern
eine Monitoring Meldung, Parkhaus Switchdown, da hab ich gedacht hä, also hab ich mich gefragt
Max weißt du was das ist, keine Ahnung, was soll das sein, ich wusste gar nicht dass
wir ein Parkhaus haben und dann meinten die ja ich auch nicht, niemand weiß welches Parkhaus
und niemand weiß welcher Switchdown ist, aber das Monitoring meckert Parkhaus Switchdown
oder besser gesagt Parkhaus SW Down und das ist jetzt Down und keiner weiß genau was
Down ist, das ist so der typische Business Strongs Enterprise Wahnsinn, kommt irgendeine
Monitoring Meldung, ist angeblich ganz schlimm und keiner weiß was es bedeutet, man davon
abgesehen, es hat sich auch keiner beschwert bis jetzt, dass der Parkhaus Switchdown ist,
also ergibt wenig Sinn, die lecken halt alle Critical Information, ja ist es, es ist ein
Wort, ich hab das gestern schon aufgenommen, alles, weil ich gedacht hab ich hab heut keinen
Bock zu schreiben, dann nehm ich das schon mal auf, Tag vorher, aber das ist mit AI,
also ich bin von gestern aber mit AI, also ich kann meine Antworten anpassen an den Chat
von heute und das geht nur wegen 500 EQ durch die ganzen Prime Subs, das ging doch mal,
es ging doch mal mit, war das Streamlabs, irgendeiner dieser Streaming Services hatte doch mal ein
Bug, dass du im Chat, ne nicht im Chat, nicht im Chat, in den Donation Messages, dass du
in den Donation Messages irgendwelche Sachen ausführen konntest, die du nicht ausführen
können solltest.
So nicht lang her, 1-2 Jahre, das ist das wo die ganzen Streamer Panik geschoben haben
und auf einmal irgendwas passiert ist, an Meldungen und komische Sachen waren, weil
du irgendwie die Donation Messages manipulieren konntest so ungefähr, du hast dann wahrscheinlich
auch ein Semikolon reingemacht und dann hat das irgendwas ausgeführt also.
Tja, das ist alles nicht so sicher.
Ihr müsst, ne, ne, so ihr sollt nicht spenden, zumindest nicht mir und auch nicht irgendwelchen
komischen großen Streamern und kleinen Streamern, ihr könnt davon ausgehen, ich mein außer
der Streamer der ist wirklich arm dran, ok, ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass den meisten
Streamern auf Twitch eigentlich ganz gut geht, spendet es lieber an euer lokales Tierheim
oder sowas anstatt irgendwelche random Dudes auf Twitch.
Was verdient ein Schulleiter?
Boah, das ist auch so ein Job den ich im Leben nicht machen möchte.
Wir lassen uns mal ein bisschen wieder tolle Sachen erklären.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen kaputt heute und ich hab irgendwie Kopfweh auf der linken Seite,
aber trotzdem hab ich mir gedacht, du kannst den Chet heute nicht alleine lassen, hab ich
doch angeschmissen, ist schon ein bisschen spät, ich bin bloß eineinhalb Stunden da.
Ja Chet, hab ich irgendwas verpasst, gibt es irgendwas spannendes?
Ich hab keine IT News verfolgt die letzten Tage, ich hab auch, ich war gestern, vorgestern
glaube ich auch nicht auf Twitch, ich hab nix mitbekommen, gar nix.
Instagram Hacker, oh nee, nee, nee Leute, da haben wir uns das letzte Mal ein Video
von angeguckt, das war, naja, naja, neue.net Preview, echt, achja 6, 7, Preview 6, das
hab ich gesehen, dass das raus ist, aber ich habe, 7 gibt es auch schon, nee, das hab ich
gesehen, aber da ist nix wirklich spannendes für mich dabei gewesen, irgendwelche high
IQ, feilfertige Jason Serializer Dinger, das hab ich schon gesehen, also sprich, dass du
jetzt irgendwelche Sachen Custom Serialisieren kannst, was was ich wahrscheinlich nie verwenden
werde.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich verwende eh nicht den eingebauten Jason Serializer, ich verwende
immer noch Jason.net, der Discord ist nicht am Start, den Raid Limiter hab ich noch gar
nicht gesehen, wo ist denn der Raid Limiter, das hat heise bestimmt wieder nicht reingeschrieben,
hier guck mal mal, Raid Limit, na was soll ich, na was, Announcing Raid Limiting for.net,
was, ach das ist gar nicht schlecht, das ist gar nicht so blöde, auf was bezieht sich
das, das kannst du für alles verwenden, das muss nicht zwangsläufig Netzwerk Traffic
sein, also mit Reactive Extensions ging das ja auch schon bis zum gewissen Grad, glaub
ich, hab ich nie verwendet, Mint 21 Beta Release, verwende es jemand von euch, also jetzt nicht
das Beta Release, verwendet jemand von euch regelmäßig Linux Mint, weil ich wollte morgen
ein Video machen, nicht wirklich zu Linux Mint, sondern dass Linux für viele Leute auch keine
Lösung ist, weil mein, jetzt muss ich euch mal kurz zeigen, Twitter, wobei nein, nicht
Twitter, Nitter, Nitter, YouTube ist, der YouTube Algorithmus ist nämlich der Meinung, dass
nach 96 Tagen mein Windows 11 Video ganz hart Promoted werden muss, hab ich nichts dagegen,
soll mir recht sein, ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sag, nein YouTube, bitte Promote meine
Videos nicht, aber YouTube ist der Meinung gewesen, 69 Days, jetzt wird es mal Zeit das
Video zu Promoten und ich hab jetzt unter dem Video relativ oft gelesen, also es geht
um dieses Video, es geht um dieses Video ja und ich hab jetzt hier schon echt, ich kann
es euch jetzt nicht alles zeigen, aber wenn ihr hier durch scrollen würdet, was ich ja
mache, weil ich lese quasi fast alle Comments, gibt es viele Kommentare, die schreiben so
nach, ah bin schon lange auf Linux umgestiegen oder wird doch Zeit, dass ich auf Linux umsteige
und so Zeug und ich wollte einfach mal ein Video mitzumachen, dass für viele Leute Linux
wahrscheinlich nicht die Lösung ihrer Probleme ist, weil das ist nicht die Oma, die einfach
nur einen Browser braucht oder so, den man, der man im Zweifelsfall auch in Chrome, OS
oder sowas hinstellen könnte, das sind Leute, die sind angepisst von Windows zu Recht, aber
das sind Leute, die machen typische Windows Workflows, die machen Steam auf, schmeißen
Steam Spiele an, die machen Epic Zeug auf, spielen Fortnite und sonstige Geschichten
und verwenden irgendwelche Adobe Produkte und haste nicht gesehen, also die meisten
Nutzer werden wahrscheinlich, auch wenn sie das denken, nicht wirklich glücklich werden
mit Linux.
Dazu kommt, dass ja dank diesem tollen 50 Jahre alten Command Fenster von Windows, wo
man jetzt übrigens seit ein paar Versionen wenigstens die Schriftgröße halbwegs scrollen
kann, die Leute panische Angst vor Kommandozeilen haben und das Problem ist halt, dass du mit
Linux nicht weit kommst, wenn du Angst vor der Kommandozeile hast und ich finde das sehen
auch viele Leute falsch, die sagen dann sowas wie, ja ich verwende Linux Mint, da muss ich
auch gar nicht ins Terminal und sowas in der Richtung, aber ich finde, das ist der falsche
Ansatz, also man kann da die Linux Distributionen und auch Linux Mint jetzt nicht daran messen,
wie oft man ins Terminal muss oder nicht, weil im Vergleich zum Windows Terminal ist das
ja was positives bei Linux, wenn du was im Terminal machen kannst, weil du es dort meistens
besser konfigurieren kannst, also bei irgendwelche GUIs, unter Linux ist es umgedreht, die meisten
Konfig GUIs sind scheiße, dafür kannst du über Kommandozeile tatsächlich brauchbar
konfigurieren, was du unter Windows nicht kannst, wenn du unter Windows kein Setting GUI hast,
dann gibt es noch irgendwelche komischen Registry Hacks oder du hast verloren.
Und das heißt im Endeffekt, du kommst unter Linux nicht am Terminal vorbei, wenn du es
ordentlich verwenden willst, und das ist kein Nachteil, sondern ich finde das ist ein Vorteil,
weil eben Linux ein ordentliches Terminal hat und das Terminal eben eines der großen
Vorzüge, boh, Alter was ist das für ein Hintergrund, big image of the day, MonkaS, die gucken mich
so an, nix wie weg, aber richtig, Monkers, ja und so ein ordentliches Terminal gibt es
halt unter Windows nicht, ich meine die haben jetzt das geschafft, der hat dieses neue Windows
Terminal, das ist, naja, das ist brauchbar, das ist brauchbar, aber ganz im Ernst, mir
ist jedes Linux Terminal immer noch lieber, vor allem weil da standardmäßig Bash oder
ZSR kommt, ja es gibt jetzt ja auch die Möglichkeit mit WSL, aber selbst dann ist ein echtes
Linux mit Terminal lieber und deswegen werden die meisten Leute unter Linux wahrscheinlich
auch nicht glücklich werden, wenn sie mit dem Windows, wie sagt man heute so, mit dem
Windows Mindset rangehen, das hat auch keinen Sinn, die erwarten quasi ein Windows, was
nicht nervig ist wie Windows, aber sich sonst verhält wie Windows oder wirst du keine Linux
Distribution finden, die das macht, zumal ihre ganzen Standard Workloads, die sie so
haben von den Programmen, die sie verwenden, wahrscheinlich unter Linux so gar nicht gehen,
es gibt sicherlich den ein oder anderen, der wird dann wieder in den Kommentaren unter diesem
Video schreiben, aber Max, bei mir hat das geklappt und ich spiele alle meine Spiele
auch auf Linux, ich kann ihm jetzt nicht sagen, du erzählst Mist, weil ich weiß ja nicht
ob es stimmt, aber ich bin mir da relativ sicher, dass diese Leute Mist erzählen, weil, jetzt
mal im Ernst, man muss sie nur mal einen Blick werfen in die Kompatibilitätsliste von Wine
und wie heißt diese andere Kompatibilitätsliste, es gibt das Wine HQ und wie heißt das andere,
ja ja Proton ist da auch dabei, wie heißt denn diese Seite, Proton, ist das Proton DB
sogar, ne oder, ja doch genau, man muss ja bloß mal in diese Liste reingucken und wo
ist denn hier die Übersicht, ja also es gibt durchaus mittlerweile im Vergleich zu früher
ordentlich viele Spiele die laufen, aber ein Vielzahl und gerade der größeren neuen Games,
die rauskommen, die kannst du knicken und wenn die ihr Anti-Cheat Zeug in Zukunft nicht
anpassen kannst du es eh komplett knicken, bin ja begeistert, dass Cyberpunk wenigstens
ganz gescheit läuft, wobei man halt sagen muss, eigentlich ist alles, zumindest ist
es im Wine HQ gewesen, es ist, ok, runs perfectly after tweaks, das ist ok, also im Wine HQ
ist es halt so, alles unter Platinium kannst du eigentlich gar nicht gescheit spielen.
Das halte ich aber für ein Gerücht, das mag vielleicht bei den offiziellen Anti-Cheats
funktionieren, die Valve entwickelt hat oder vielleicht auch bei Easy Anti-Cheat was angepasst
worden ist, aber die Sachen von Valorant oder Pupke oder sonst was oder mail.ru Anti-Cheat,
was kein Witz ist, es gibt Spiele die verwenden sowas, wirst du das so nicht so einfach sehen,
so und ich finde daran sieht man es schon, es ist halt nicht so einfach, es läuft im Vergleich
zu früher sehr viel, guck mal sogar so Sachen wie Monster Hunter und so laufen, das ist
nicht schlecht, aber es gibt genug Sachen die nicht gescheit funktionieren und dann
kannst du nicht mehr das machen was die meisten Leute machen, Steam öffnen und sich ein
neues Game kaufen, auf Play drücken und spielen, das ist dann halt nicht und damit hast du
ganz andere Probleme wenn du GPU pass-through und VM machst, zumal das definitiv kein Einsteiger
Thema ist, was einfach mal irgendeinen Umsteiger macht, zumal die Umsteiger hier weg wollen
von Windows, genau Epic Store und Gedöns gibt es ja auch noch, also es ist halt nicht
so rosig wie sich das manche vorstellen und wenn Leute damit halt rangehen, ihnen geht
Windows auf den Sack und deswegen wechseln sie jetzt auf Linux, denen kann ich Brief und
Siegel drauf geben, diese Leute wenn sie quasi Linux als reinen Windows Ersatz sehen und
erwarten dass es quasi wie Windows ist, nur ohne das nervige, denen gebe ich da Brief und
Siegel drauf, die sind in zwei Wochen wieder unter Windows und haben da keinen Bock mehr
drauf, deswegen finde ich ist es auch überhaupt nicht förderlich, es gab ja mal so ein Trend
dass Linux Distributionen aussehen wollten wie Windows, ich weiß nicht ob es das heute
noch in dieser Form gibt, aber es gab mal vor ein paar Jahren so einen richtigen Trend,
da gab es am laufenden Band neue Distributionen die geworben haben damit dass sie quasi für
Windows Umsteiger sind und quasi so aussehen und sich so bedienen lassen wie Windows unter
Linus, ob es jetzt quasi Startmenü hatten und gescheit vorinstallierte Sachen, manche
haben sogar Windows Hintergründe genommen und sowas und das finde ich war echt bedenklich
nicht wegen Copyright Zeug, das ist mir vollkommen egal, ich fand das bedenklich weil das die
Leute quasi noch bestärkt hat da drin auf Screenshots zu glauben, das wäre irgendwie
die 1 zu 1 Windows Replacement und das ist es halt nicht, spätestens wenn du deinen
Browser aufmachst, gehst du auf YouTube und stellst fest, das ist das erste Beispiel was
mir jetzt einfällt, du gehst auf YouTube, im Browser, stellst fest, oh gucke mal ich
habe hier auf einmal 80% CPU Auslastung beim Video gucken und dann musst du irgendwie
versuchen GPU Decoding unter Linux einzurichten, vielleicht tue ich den Browser Entwicklern
auch unrecht, vielleicht geht das mittlerweile easy out of the box überall, aber ich habe
meine Zweifel, die haben das Active Directory kopiert, nicht schlecht, naja gut Zamba macht
schon lange Active Directory aber halt nicht in den Details wie das Microsoft macht, Murksor
Dankeschön für den Sub, ich mach große Bogen um Windows und ja also wenn ihr hier durchscrollt
ihr werdet sehen ganz guck hier der erste schon Linux, Windows wird irgendwann mal ein
Linux mit Windows Oberfläche sein, da habe ich halt meine Zweifel ob das so ist, wie
kommt der denn da drauf, ich finde ich benutze es zwar kaum oder ich hauptsächlich Mac
oder Sony aber schon toll, ok ich lass mir gefallen das Windows 11 modern aussieht toll
weiß nicht, Windows wird irgendwann mal ein Linux mit Windows Oberfläche sein, im Leben
nicht, garantiert nicht, ganz viele Leute schreiben hier sowas, Linux umsteigen, Linux umschreien,
genau hier, bei mir kommt nach Windows 10 wahrscheinlich Ubuntu oder Linux Mint oder
ähnlich zum Einsatz, ja ja das denkt man sich so aber wie gesagt ich gebe euch Brief
und Siegel drauf, die Leute sind in zwei Wochen wieder da, wenn die damit, wenn die halt mit
diesem, das ist ja quasi wie Windows nur ohne nervigen Sachen von Windows rangehen, den
Witz verstehe ich nicht, ich vermute du möchtest sagen, dass man unter Windows dann auch Arch
by the way sagen kann oder was oder wie jetzt, Microsoft ist Legacy Code doch vollkommen
egal, ich mein sieht das irgendwie so aus und auch ein besseres Beispiel, ich hab das
ultimative Beispiel Leute für Legacy Code, sieht das irgendwie so aus, sieht das hier
irgendwie so aus als interessiert sich Microsoft für Legacy Code, das da guckt mal, das hier,
machen die einen Eindruck als interessieren die sich für Legacy Code ja, guckt euch mal
das Icon an, das ist 1 zu 1, 1 zu 1 aus Windows 3.1, übrigens der Witz, dass das immer noch
der Icon Customize Dialog ist, ich mein ich denk mir halt Icon Customize kann doch jetzt
nicht so das abgedrehte Ding sein, das ist immer noch so letztes Jahr tausendes, guckt
euch das hier an, das ist einfach, das kommt aus Windows 3.11, guckt euch mal Pixel an,
das ist ein 16x16 Pixel Bild oder ein 8x8 Pixel, das ist ein 2x2 Pixel Bild oder so
wenig Details wie das hat, Windows 11 Briefing, ich weiß wir haben zusammen geguckt hier,
ist immer noch so, also die sind, ist nicht so als würde die das interessieren, als dass
das das Legacy Code hat, das ist denen vollkommen egal, die Leute haben ja gar keine andere
Wahl als Windows zu verwenden, zumindest die Leute die eben sowas machen wollen wie Epic,
Steam, GOG, gibt es eigentlich GOG für Linux? Wahrscheinlich nicht oder? Nö, siehste? Oder
muss man das mit Wine emulieren oder? Ne ne, Microsoft hat eine andere Taktik, die lassen
den Legacy Code einfach unverändert drin und das schimmelt da vor sich hin, die maintainen
da einfach nix mehr. Habt ihr übrigens, ach mir fällt doch was ein, habt ihr mitbekommen
zum Red Pleat? Habt ihr das mitgekriegt? Wo man jetzt wieder Secrets aus dem Ram liegen kann? Und soll ich euch mal was sagen? Also wenn ich euch jetzt frage, was meint ihr? Welches Betriebssystem
ist davon, oder sagen wir mal, welches Betriebssystem ist nicht betroffen? Windows oder Linux? Was
meint ihr? Solaris, ja, ich sag's euch, Windows, zumindest vor zwei Tagen wo ich geguckt habe,
es war diesmal tatsächlich so, dass anscheinend, ich warte mal gucken was Heise dazu sagt,
also ich hab nämlich bei Intel im Blog geguckt, ja steht ja hier, ich hab bei Intel im Blog
Eintrag geguckt und Windows ist nicht betroffen, anscheinend ist wirklich nur Linux betroffen
diesmal, wobei man halt sagen muss, es ist kein Linux Problem an sich, sondern es ist
immer noch ein Problem von der CPU. Warum kann ich euch ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht genau erklären?
Wahrscheinlich weil Linux irgendwelche FIFAT Optimierungen hat, die Windows nicht hat,
das weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, so genau hab ich es mir nicht durchgelesen, dass ich
das erklären könnte. Aber was sagt denn Heise dazu? Hier, keine zusätzliche Bedrohung Windows
hat. Ist doch geil, IT News für Profis, steht halt nix drin, warum Windows nicht betroffen
ist, aber ok. Ja diesen Blog Eintrag von Intel, den kenn ich. Ne, das nicht. Ach hier, genau,
Intel Windows EBRS verwendet. Ich kann euch beim besten Willen nicht sagen, was EBRS ist.
International Business Reply Service. Branch Restricted Speculation. Ok, das ist irgendwelche
CPU Optimierungsgeschichten, dass die, also ich rate jetzt einfach anhand des Namens,
ich weiß es nicht, dass die CPU quasi versucht zu erraten, was als nächstes ausgeführt
werden muss bei einem IF. Das war ja das Problem auch schon bei Meltdown, ja bei Meltdown war
es so, falls sich noch irgendjemand an Meltdown überhaupt erinnern kann, weiß gar nicht,
ob es die Seite noch gibt. Gibt es die Webseite von Meltdown überhaupt noch? Na wurscht,
zumindest so war es ja auch bei Meltdown, wenn ich das noch richtig zusammen bekomme, wie
das funktioniert hat. Und ich denke mal, das wird in eine ähnliche Kerbe schlagen. Bei
Meltdown war das ja so, die haben, die haben der CPU gesagt, hier führ mal aus und dann
kam ein IF und die CPU hat den falschen Branch vom IF ausgeführt. Predictive. Es kann sein,
dass ich es durcheinander bringe, aber so ungefähr. Also sprich, es ist ja so, wenn
die CPU was ausführt, die macht ja quasi Out of Order Execution, also sprich, ne Moment,
nicht Out of Order Execution. Es kann sein, dass ich es mit Spectre, es kann sein, dass
ich es mit Spectre durcheinander bringe. Ich bin mir aus dem Kopf nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Zumindest bei einem dieser Sachen, bei Meltdown oder Spectre war es so, die CPU hat predicted,
was als nächstes ausgeführt wird und normalerweise läuft das so, die CPU kommt an ein IF und
naja gut, die CPU muss ja dann warten oder nachladen oder was auch immer oder eben schon
mal weiter ausführen in der Hoffnung, sie führt das Richtige aus und kann das Ergebnis
nachher verwenden und wenn dann rauskommt, dass das IF eigentlich den anderen Branch,
dass der andere Branch ausgeführt werden sollte, also sprich, der ELS Branch und es hat den,
hat es im IF ausgeführt, es hat an der falschen Stelle weiter gerechnet quasi, dann hat die
CPU das verworfen und du hast nie in dem ursprünglichen Programm das Ergebnis gesehen. Also dementsprechend
konntest du nicht einfach sagen, ich führ jetzt mal was aus, also du konntest beispielsweise
sowas hier machen, sinngemäß, wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, du konntest
quasi sinngemäß sowas hier machen hier, was weiß ich. IF load aus memory so bla bla bla,
wenn das der Wert da drinnen gleich gleich kackel ist, dann führst du aus Printf null
oder ist eigentlich egal, dann führst du aus Print, dann gab es ein ELS und im ELS stand
dann sowas wie hier Open oder was weiß ich hier, Colonel Adresse Read Root Passwort,
so sinngemäß war das. So und jetzt ist die CPU hier an dieses IF gekommen, das ist jetzt
die ganz vereinfachte Variante, wer es genau wissen will, ich hab mal ein Video dazu gemacht
und da wusste ich noch besser von was ich rede, ist aber auch schon 2 Jahre her, zumindest
wenn die CPU an diese Stelle gekommen ist, muss nachgeladen werden aus dem Speicher,
das heißt die CPU muss warten, weil es muss erstmal aus dem RAM nachgeladen werden, die
CPUs heute sind relativ clever, die CPU versucht jetzt quasi zu erraten, welcher dieser beiden
Sachen wohl ausgeführt werden muss und jetzt gehen wir mal von aus, die CPU führt weiter
Sachen aus, normalerweise müsste die hier warten, weil laden aus dem Speicher aber warten
ist doof, dementsprechend macht die CPU einfach schon mal predictive weiter, das heißt die
CPU redet jetzt, aha der ELS Branch von diesem IF soll ausgeführt werden und in diesem ELS
steht, ach wir lesen mal aus dem Kernelspeicherbereich das Rootpasswort aus, so, ähm, dann kommt
die CPU zurück und stellt fest, oh Moment, Moment, Moment, ähm, eigentlich sollte das
Printf ausgeführt werden und ich verwerf das hier wieder, oder selbst wenn, selbst wenn
das ELS ausgeführt werden soll, dann gibt es irgendwie einen, was weiß ich, Permission
Denied Fehler oder sowas, den Permission Denied Fehler gibt es aber erst, wenn das hier wirklich
ausgeführt werden soll, so, das ist einfach dazu da aus Performance Optimierungsgründen,
dass die CPU weiter rechnen kann und nicht warten muss und meistens funktioniert das
auch, weil wenn die CPU weiter gerechnet hat und es soll wirklich das hier ausgeführt
werden, ist gut, ist schneller, weil die CPU nicht warten musste und das schon mal im Voraus
ausgerechnet hat.
So, und was die jetzt gemacht haben bei Meltdown, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe, die
CPU verwirft das hier komplett, also du siehst nie in deinem Programm wirklich den Wert
aus dem Kerneladressbereich, aber, du kannst, und das ist das, was halt diese wahnsinnige
Fivehead-Geschichte bei Meltdown gewesen ist, du kannst jetzt durch Timing, also durch Abfragen,
kannst du versuchen Sachen aus dem Speicher auszulesen, nochmal, die darfst du zwar nach
wie vor nicht auslesen, aber an der Stelle, wo der Zugriff auf den Speicher schneller
geht, weißt du, es war die Stelle, wo vorher schon mal Predictive was ausgelesen wurde,
also du kannst quasi dann dadurch erraten, an welchem Array-Index du auf den Speicher
zugreifst und der Speicherzugriff schneller ist, das kommt dann wohl nicht aus dem Speicher,
sondern aus dem CPU-Cache und wenn es aus dem CPU-Cache kommt, dann müssen das die Sachen
sein, also der Index ist quasi der Byte-Wert, der vorher aus dem Kerneladressbereich ausgelesen
wurde, so ungefähr hat das damals bei Meltdown funktioniert und das war halt echt sehr Sixheader
mäßig und diese ganze Side-Channel-Attacken, das ist äußerst Fivehead alles, das ist
wirklich Massive Brain, ich hab dazu mal ein Video gemacht hier, gucken wir uns jetzt nicht
an 28 Minuten, da hab ich irgendwie Array-Zugriffe im RAM und so gesagt, genau das hier unten
ist das eigentliche Assembly-Zeug, was ausgeführt wird, da steht ja auch die Erklärung und zumindest
wird dann geguckt, wie schnell das ganze geht und man bekommt es anhand des Indexes raus,
was denn wohl der Wert war, der aus dem Kernelbereich ausgelesen wurde, das ist nicht schnell, das
ist auch nicht gut zuverlässig, aber man kann es halt viel und oft ausführen.
So, genau und ich vermute mal in der Richtung sind diese ganzen neuen Attacken auch, ohne
dass ich es weiß, wie gesagt, ich hab das hier alles nur überflogen, also ich hab keine
Ahnung, ob das in dem Fall exakt auch sowas ist, aber ich vermute es jetzt einfach mal,
wenn es hier irgendwie was von Pranch Prediction und sowas steht.
Ja und lustigerweise ist Windows nicht betroffen, wie geht es dem Parkour-Switch, ja hab ich
am Anfang was zu erzählt, also es kam gestern bei unserem Support, kam eine Monitoring-Meldung,
Parkour-Switch down und da haben sich alle so gedacht, was und dann hab ich das mitbekommen,
weil die haben mich gefragt, haben gesagt, sag mal Max, was denn für ein Parkour-Switch,
kennst du den?
Ich hab gesagt, nee, kenn ich den, haben wir denn ein Parkour-Switch?
Und sie meint, nee, wir haben überhaupt kein Parkour-Switch, also ich weiß nicht welcher
Parkour-Switch und es wusste auch keiner und ein bisschen rumgefragt, keiner wusste,
ob wir ein Parkhaus haben, die Leute aus dem Support nachgefragt, ja welches Parkhaus,
welcher Switch, ist irgendwas kaputt?
Nee, wir haben kein Parkhaus, keiner wusste welches Parkhaus und wir haben jetzt die Vermutung,
dass es wahrscheinlich kein Parkhaus ist, sondern einfach der Keller, wo es halt ein
paar Parkplätze gibt und dort ist angeblich was ausgefallen, aber es ist nichts kaputt
und es ist auch nicht, dass sich einer beschwert hat und es weiß auch niemand welcher Switch,
also der Parkhaus-Switch ist immer noch kaputt.
So ist das halt, so ist das halt, wenn man irgendwie 15.000 Netzwerkgeräte oder so über
Frankfurt verteilt hat, keine Ahnung, dann blickt man halt irgendwann nicht mehr durch.
Der Profi ist am Werk wieder.
Das ist jetzt quasi wie Microsoft Legacy Code, genau, jetzt sei mal froh, dass es nicht
Stolen Access Point ist, weil Stolen Access Point könntest du Free Entertainment machen,
Stolen Laptop Free, Moment, Moment.
Never Sub, Never Donated, Free Entertainment, Neighbors Wi-Fi, Stolen Laptop, keine Ahnung,
ich krieg's nicht mal alles zusammen.
Never Sub, Never Donated, Adblock On, Stolen Neighbors Wi-Fi, Mama's Haus, Stolen Solar
Panel, Stolen Suns, Moment, das ist nicht den, den ich kenne.
Wie wäre es mit einer Doku, für was, von was?
Moin, wie bezahlst du eigentlich bei deinen Kurztricks um die Welt, dein YouTube war gestern
in Indien, da ging's nur Visa.
PayPal, bezahle ich die.
PayPal, kannst PayPal bezahlen, YouTube Indian.
Du musst dafür ein Payment Profil in deinem Account anlegen, One Only Fans, wieso wollt
ihr Fußbilder oder was ist hier los, oder Finger, Gatschi Roll, Knie, auch, ja okay,
da gibt's ja Leute, die stehen auf Knie, das ist auf One Only Fans bestimmt verboten.
Achso, das meinst du, nee, sowas gibt's bei uns nicht, ja doch schon, aber anscheinend
hat's auch nichts gebracht.
So gibt's, empfiehlt uns YouTube irgendwas, irgendwas spannendes, zeig mal hier, probably
cooles Klitsch, das ist ein MW2 Klitsch, also ein MW2 2011 oder wann das kam Klitsch.
Der Kerl schon wieder, wetten, ich guck das Video jetzt nicht, ich guck das Video jetzt
nicht, wetten, dass das exploit wieder total unspektakulär ist, also so nach dem Motto,
man kann sich durch Gutscheincodes 30 Cent generieren oder so und auch nicht unendlich
sondern immer nur eins auf einmal oder sowas, die Videos sind teilweise echt total übertrieben,
der erzählt die ganze Zeit so, als kommt jetzt der größte Leak und der größte Trick
aller Zeiten und dann ist es irgendwas total Banales.
Can you code on IP, ja kann man schon, will man wahrscheinlich aber nicht, underwater
ambient mix, das hebe ich mir mal auf, das ist wenn es wieder so warm ist, brauchen wir
den underwater Nintendo Mix, Ban, Deno und das Ende von Node.js, genauso wenig wie Deno,
wobei die machen echt gute Videos, guck von denen öfters was, genauso wenig wie Deno
das Ende war von Node.js, wird Ban das Ende von Node.js sein, das Node.js Ökosystem ist
einfach viel zu riesig, ich sag nur, okay wir gucken den Glitch jetzt, wenn ich schon
ausführlich angeklickt habe, ich sag nur is odd und is even, ah jetzt ist er außerhalb
der Map, okay und jetzt, ich mein, ist jetzt nicht so als gibt es da viel zu sehen oder
so ne, ich mein es sieht außerhalb der Map exakt so aus, wie ich es von einer Call of
Duty Map erwartet habe, nämlich nix, ah Moment, es geht noch weiter, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, das ist tatsächlich cool, das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, lass ich mir
gefallen, der Anfang war lame, aber das ist tatsächlich ganz nice, achso ne gut, ich
dachte der wird jetzt irgendwie abgesetzt oder so, das war einfach so random scripted Call
of Duty Heli, der ist da lang geflogen, hat aber nix weiter gemacht, okay nice, das war
alles mal bescheid, ja, in Call of Duty, nicht alle diese random, nicht nur die random, sondern
die spawnen diese Teammates, das war in Call of Duty 4 auch schon so, da hast du total viele
gesehen, die irgendwelche, na also Entwicklernamen hatten, ja, also alle sind es glaube ich nicht,
aber ich weiß, dass es viele Entwicklernamen sind, na es gibt doch in Call of Duty das,
wo du auf die Fernsehstation aufs Dach läufst und da schreit der Typ auch irgendwas von
wegen Apra Hamson get down und dann guckst du ihm ab, Spann ist halt der Apra Hamson am
Start.
Okay, was lassen wir, jetzt müssen wir irgendwas gucken, sonst wird es mir zu langweilig und
außerdem hab ich Kopf weh seit heute Mittag wieder, ich hätte mehr laufen müssen heute,
ich bin bloß ausnahmsweise, hab ich wahrscheinlich wieder zugenommen heute, ich bin heute ausnahmsweise
noch 45 Minuten kurz vorhin und wieder heim, wie viel weitere Tabs, kann ich dir sagen,
ganz einfach, RAM, gar nichts, nix und da läuft noch eine VM, das Ding ist, also, ich
also, da kannst du noch mal dreimal so viel aufmachen, das interessiert dir nicht, Super
Mario World hoffnungslos klitscht, okay, gucken wir uns vielleicht auch an, Gaming am Ende,
weißt du nicht was du zocken sollst, das ist tatsächlich so, ich weiß nicht was ich zocken
soll, das ist richtig, wobei ich immer mal wieder die ein oder anderen doch ganz netten
kleinen Spielchen auf Twitch, äh, nicht auf Twitch, ja doch auf Twitch, vielleicht manchmal
auch bei Livestreams, auf Steam finde, ich wurde die letzten Jahre über maßlos von
den meisten AAA Games, auf die ich mich gefreut habe, enttäuscht, letztes großes Beispiel
dürfte, ihr werdet das kaum erraten, ja, Battlefield 2042 sein, gucken wir mal, wie
sieht es eigentlich bei New World aus, noch mal kurz kecken, hast du schon das JWST, was
für ein Ding, okay, New World kackt weiter ab, Battlefield kackt auch weiter ab, excellent,
also alles, alles beim alten alles wie erwartet, so wir brauchen ein bisschen High IQ Content,
wir lassen uns jetzt CassandraDB in 100 Sekunden erklären, zack, ich habe übrigens ein Vorstellungsgespräch
am Montag, nicht wirklich Vorstellungsgespräch so, aber ja doch, so eine Art Vorstellungsgespräch,
James Webb Space Telescope, achso, die habe ich schon gesehen, ja, also das ist eh, das
ist eh wieder so eine typische Sache, das geht auch nur im Jahr 2022, ja, es hat sich jemand
bei mir gemeldet, nach dem Stream letztens, wo ich gesagt habe, ich bin gerade auf der
Suche, so mal gucken, neue Jobangebote, hat sich bei mir gemeldet und hat gemeint, Max,
passt es dir am Montag, lass mal drüber reden, so, habe ich erstmal zurückgeschrieben,
Moment, Moment, so und so und bla bla bla, hat er nochmal geantwortet und gesagt, ja
okay, lass mal nächsten Montag, mal gucken, mal gucken was da rauskommt, ich mach das
hauptsächlich erstmal, dass ich da ein bisschen Übung wieder kriege drin, Antwort okay, auf
geht's, ja, muss man sich erstmal einig sein, was Bezahlung, Arbeitszeit und alles mögliche
angeht, so einfach und so schnell geht das auch nicht, außerdem habe ich, bei so lang
Kündigungsfrist habe ich gar nicht, wenn ich jetzt, ich muss mich aber beeilen, aber
mal gucken, mal gucken, was miese Brise im Job, naja, ich will es jetzt nicht, ich will
jetzt nicht wieder von Anfang, ich habe mich ja der Letzte drüber ausgelassen, es gibt
bei uns eine größere Umstrukturierung und ich habe jetzt einen neuen Chef, das finde
ich gar nicht so schlimm, wobei ich meinen alten Chef mochte, sowohl jobtechnisch als
auch ihn selbst, aber mein neuer Chef ist auch okay, was mir persönlich aber am meisten
auf den Keks geht, ist, dass man sich jetzt dazu entschieden hat, dass diese ganzen Home-Office-Regelungen,
die wir hatten, wieder nach und nach aufgehoben werden und ich habe das jetzt an vielen Stellen
schon angesprochen, also ich habe gesagt, also ein Tag die Woche kein Problem, vielleicht
mal zwei Tage, aber hauptsächlich ein Tag, da kann man ja drüber reden, aber insgesamt
werde ich nicht wieder Großteil der Woche anrücken, das könnt ihr vergessen, das mache
ich nicht mehr, mir geht es zu gut dabei, also was Rückenprobleme angeht, was Kopfschmerzen
angeht, alles, mir geht es viel besser und ich mache unterm Strich auch noch mehr, also
es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn und ich werde das auch nicht mehr machen, ich habe das an
ganz vielen Stellen jetzt auch schon gesagt und außer, dass ich da immer so ein bisschen
gewunden wird, ich meine, die können ja teilweise gerade im mittleren Management da auch nicht
wirklich viel machen, wenn es die Ansage von oben ist, verstehe ich ja auch, bleibt mir
zunächst alles da übrig, wie zumindest mal, wie nennt man es so schön, seine Möglichkeiten
zu evaluieren, dann einfach mal schauen, was sich ergibt und wenn sich was ergibt, was
ich wirklich cool finde, dann bin ich weg, ganz einfach, ich habe nicht vor abzuhauen,
sage ich euch ganz ehrlich, ich finde es dort, wo ich bin, eigentlich nicht schlecht, leider
ist das eine hoffnungslose Boomer Firma, was das angeht, ich meine Bank in Frankfurt, ihr
könnt euch vorstellen, es gibt außer vielleicht dem Vatikan nichts, was konservativer ist
als eine deutsche Bank, also nicht die deutsche Bank, als eine deutsche Bank, es ist echt
der Wahnsinn, also der Papst vielleicht, aber ansonsten nicht viel und die sind so schwer,
die suchen, letztens habe ich erfahren, wir suchen irgendwie um die 50 neue Leute, weil
es sind schon ein paar Leute abgehauen und es hauen jetzt auch noch ein paar Leute ab,
die suchen 50 neue Leute, habe ich gelesen, so und weißt du, ok, ich muss sagen, ich weiß
es nicht komplett, Gesamt-IT, ich weiß es nur von drei Teams, weiß ich es und diese
drei Teams machen bestimmt nicht unerheblichen Teil der Gesamt-IT aus und wisst ihr wie viele
neue Leute, die gefunden haben bis jetzt, ratet mal, ihr kommt nicht drauf, es sind
nicht 0, es sind nicht 0, naja, ok, ich sage es euch, es sind 0 bis 2, weil sie haben zwei
gefunden, die sich dazu bereit erklärt haben mal probemäßig herzukommen und sich das
anzugucken und anzuhören und denen sie einen Vertrag geschickt haben, ob die diesen Vertrag
jetzt unterschreiben, das ist noch nicht klar, aber ich meine 2 von 50, da läuft es richtig,
ja und naja, was willst du machen, ja, aber es ist ja auch klar, einer unserer Personalleute
hat mir letztens mal erzählt, er hat ein Vorstellungsgespräch, also von irgendeinem
Personalvermittler, der hat bei ihm angerufen und hat gesagt, hier Herr XY, ich hätte da
jemand geeignet, ein Kandidat für Sie, richtig gut, hat er sich angeguckt, meint, ja, passt
vom Profil her richtig gut, lass mal Vorstellungsgespräch machen, jo, wir machen Vorstellungsgespräch
und dann meinte dann dieser Recruiter-Typ noch, ach ja, wie sind dann bei Ihnen so die
Homeoffice-Regelungen und da hat der Personale halt ehrlich geantwortet und hat gesagt,
ja, jetzt während Corona noch recht gut, aber danach halt keine Regelung und eher weniger
und es hat keine 5 Minuten gedauert, dann hat der Recruiter-Personalverschacherungstyp
wieder angerufen und hat gesagt, ah, Kandidat hat abgesagt, direkt gelieft, Alter, ja, pech
gehabt, also ich denke, eigentlich könnte ich es sich gar nicht erlauben, wenn die wirklich
Leute haben wollen, da so Boomer-mäßig drauf zu sein, ja, auf so Leute habe ich ja gar
keinen Bock, auf so Leute habe ich ja gar keinen Bock, die immer, die immer so wichtig
tun oder so, so, so schlau tun, wisst ihr, es gibt was, gegen solche Leute habe ich wirklich
eine richtige Abneigung, ja, es gibt Leute, die tun so immer, wie soll man das, wie soll
man das beschreiben, die tun immer so überheblich, als hätten sie Plan, obwohl sie gar keinen
Plan haben und selbst wenn du es schon längst gemerkt hast, dass sie keinen Plan haben,
ziehen sie diese Show weiter durch, anstatt dann einfach normal zu reden, ja, also mein
Lieblingsbeispiel, was ich in den letzten Zeiten hatte in dieser Richtung mit Leuten,
die wirklich überzeugt Schwachsinn erzählen, war ein Entwickler, da ging es darum, Agent
Zertifikat ist abgelaufen und die haben in ihrer App gecheckt, ob das Zertifikat vom
richtigen Herausgeber ist, was ziemlich bescheuert ist, weil man sollte nicht den Herausgeber
checken, sondern man sollte die Gültigkeit checken, solange der Herausgeber im Truststore
ist, ist alles in Ordnung, moin Michael5 Spieljahren, zumindest jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt
ja der Hit, das habe ich euch auch vor ein paar Monaten schon erzählt, auf einmal sagt
er so, ja was erzählt ihr denn hier überhaupt, wie Zertifikat abgelaufen, ich habe gerade
nachgeguckt, das Zertifikat läuft bis 2035 und ich dachte mir schon so, alter du bist
ein krasser Senior Entwickler und du kennst den Unterschied zwischen dem Zertifikat und
dem Zertifikat der CA nicht, also Chet für euch die Erklärung, also bei so einem Zertifikat,
ich zeige euch mal, Hallo, kann man da nicht, Chet kann man da nicht mal drauf klicken
in Chrome, ah jetzt kann man wieder drauf klicken, ok alles gut, also wenn man sich
so an das Zertifikat anguckt, da sieht man hier die Zertifikat Details, oh Gott ich weiß
nicht wie man das unter Windows sieht, ich weiß nicht wie man das unter Windows sieht,
aber zumindest sieht man hier die Zertifikat Details und in der Regel ist das hier das
wichtige beim Zertifikat, das ist nämlich die Domain wofür das ausgestellt wurde und
dann gibt es Valet 2, das ist wie lange ist das ganze gültig, so und das Zertifikat
war abgelaufen und der hat geguckt nicht beim Zertifikat, sondern bei, ich habe keine Ahnung
wo das unter Windows steht ehrlich gesagt, wo finde ich denn das Root CA, wo finde ich
denn die Root CA unter Windows, Third Pass, ahja der hat hier geguckt, der hat hier geguckt
seht ihr bis 2027, der hat quasi, der hat quasi das Zertifikat der Zertifizierungsstelle
angeguckt, also sprich der hat sich das Zertifikat angeguckt der Stelle die unser Zertifikat
ausgestellt hat und der hat sich da immer hingestellt und hat so wahnsinnig überheblich
getan so nach dem Motto, was erzählt der denn hier überhaupt das Zertifikat, ist bis 2035
lauer, dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, mann und der hat das weiter durchgezogen ja, ich
habe dann gesagt, nein das ist doch das Zertifikat von der Root CA, das ist nicht unser Zertifikat
und der hat das weiter, der ist noch da, da ist Senior FyFat Entwickler bei uns und der
hat das gnadenlos weiter durchgezogen, der kam dann immer wieder mit an, ja aber ja dann
lass uns doch das nächste mal gucken, dass wir auch bis 2035 machen und so und ich denke
mir halt immer so, meine Güte jetzt halt doch mal die Klappe alter und tu nicht so wichtig
obwohl wir alles schon durchschaut haben, dass du es nicht geblickt hast, es ist ja überhaupt
kein Problem was nicht zu checken ja, eins hab ich ja auch mittlerweile schon gelernt
bei uns auf der Arbeit, in Meetings ist es immer relativ gut so aufzutreten als wüsste
mann wovon man spricht, aber ich persönlich allein schon weil ich das irgendwie, keine
Ahnung, cringe finde, wenn ich merke, dass das Blödsinn ist oder ich es falsch verstanden
habe, was wie es gemeint ist oder so, dann sag ich halt, ja ok wusste ich nicht, ist
doch alles in Ordnung, ich gebe auch nicht gerne zu wenn ich keine Ahnung hab, ist doch
auch, ja aber gerade bei sowas, ich finde es ultra nervig, wenn Leute diese Show dann
einfach noch eine halbe Stunde oder 45 Minuten durchziehen, obwohl man sie eigentlich schon
längst durchschaut hat, dass es Blödsinn ist was sie erzählt haben oder auch was mich
auch mega triggert ist, wenn dann einer sagt, ich konstruiere mal irgendwie so ein Beispiel,
Beispiel Dialog ja, wenn dann irgend einer sagt, ja dafür kann man dann Framework XY
verwenden und man antwortet dann, ja das geht, aber da müsste man da und da noch was dazu
programmieren und ich glaube in der Standard Library ist das auch schon drinnen, warum
nehmen wir nicht das und dann kommt als Antwort, ja sag ich doch, das ist genau das was ich
meine, kennt ihr Leute die so antworten so nach dem Motto, sie sagen was, du sagst was
drauf wo halt rauskommt, dass das was sie gesagt haben eigentlich keine so gute Idee
ist und dann ist ihre Antwort, ja das meine ich doch, natürlich so ist es selbstverständlich
und dann denke ich mir auch immer, alter man Leute, ah geht mir nicht auf den Sack, umut
ich glaube es gibt niemand gerne zu wenn er keine Ahnung hat oder Mist erzählt hat, aber
es ist ja ein Unterschied ob man es doof findet oder ob man drauf beharrt, dass man Recht
hat obwohl man halt Blödsinn erzählt hat, wir hatten mal einen, da muss ich jetzt gerade
noch was erzählen bevor wir jetzt wirklich hier was angucken, wir hatten mal einen Russe
auf der Arbeit, äh Kollege bei mir und der hat, ich hab das nie wieder so erlebt, der
hat so mega vorsichtig alles formuliert, ich weiß nicht was die ihm in seinen alten Jobs
angetan haben, zumindest, der saß schräg neben mir und manchmal kam es halt vor, dass
ich irgendwas getippt habe und der hat zufällig in meine Richtung geguckt, also der hat nicht
mal einen Bildschirm analysiert oder so, aber der hat dann keine Ahnung, im Raum bisschen
rum geguckt und ich hab halt was getippt, der hat halt zufällig bei mir auf den Bildschirm
geguckt oder beim Hinsetzen hat er bei mir auf den Bildschirm geguckt und ihm ist halt
aufgefallen, so was weiß ich, ich hab Mist getippt, ja so keine Ahnung, ich hab ssh-großp
gemacht für port anstatt minus klein p oder sowas als Beispiel und jeder andere bei uns
im Team hätte gesagt Max hier guck mal, hast dich verschrieben oder Max was tippst du für
nen Mist, stimmt doch überhaupt nicht und der hat das immer so extrem vorsichtig ausgedrückt,
das hab ich vorher noch nie erlebt und noch nie nachher erlebt, der hat sich dann hingesetzt
und hat sich dann von der Seite angeguckt und dann musstest du aus dem Augenwinkel sehen,
dass der dich anguckt und wenn du gemerkt hast, dass der dich anguckt, dann musst du
dann sagen, ja was gibt's denn und dann meinte er so, ja also ich hab gesehen, was du da
tippst und es gäbe da auch noch andere Möglichkeiten, das ist viel zu direkt, sorry Leute, das war
viel zu direkt, der hätte dann eher gesagt, es gibt noch Möglichkeiten, das Kommando
zu verbessern oder irgendwie sowas, der war so ultra vorsichtig bei allem, wie er das
formuliert hat, ich muss dann auch manchmal irgendwann sagen, ja sag doch, dass ich Mist
getippt hab, ich weiß, ja sag, was ist verkehrt, der war wirklich, ich hab das noch nie erlebt,
der war so ultra vorsichtig, so haben es besteh da eventuell ja vielleicht noch Optimierungsmöglichkeiten
an der Sache, aber ich will auf keinen Fall sagen, dass das schlecht ist, was du getippt
hast, der war richtig krass drauf in der Richtung, der war wirklich so vorsichtig, leider ist
der auch abgehauen, die guten Leute hauen ja immer ab, der war gut, der hat durchgeblickt
und der war nett, das in Kombination ist selten, du hast oftmals Leute, die blicken durch,
sind deppen und umgedreht, aber so Leute, die richtig durchblicken und Ahnung haben, nett
sind und nicht nerven auf dort, das ist wirklich selten, ja, naja, ok, also was, hatte vor
zwei Tagen, die eine von den Personalteilen war super drauf, achso, das hab ich ja grad
schon gelesen, ja, ja, das ist bei uns auch teilweise ganz schrecklich, die sind der Meinung,
dass man anscheinend nur gescheit arbeiten kann, wenn man vor Ort ist, wobei wie wohl
gemerkt, so die direkten Vorgesetzten bei uns da wahrscheinlich gar nichts für können,
das ist halt die Ansage von ganz high oben Management und ich glaube, das ist einfach
zu Boomer mäßig bei uns, wir machen immer so viele Umstrukturierungen, ja, aber ich
hab's noch nie erlebt, dass tatsächlich mal höheres Management umstrukturiert wurde
und gerade bei den Entscheidungen, wie viel da ins Klo gegriffen wurde die letzten Jahre
über, frag ich mich, ob man dort tatsächlich keinerlei Einsicht hat oder was das Einsicht
keinerlei Selbstkritik kennt oder es nur nicht zugeben will, ich weiß es nicht, würdest
du in die Dienstleistungsbranche gehen, IT-Support, nein, niemals würde ich in IT-Support gehen,
ich bin absolut nicht geeignet für den IT-Support und ich hab wahrscheinlich auch viel zu wenig
Ahnung von dem, was man da supporten muss, da muss man wahrscheinlich Windows oder Active
Directory oder sowas supporten, da hab ich keine Ahnung von, nee, bei uns ist es noch
schlimmer, bei uns sagen sie immer, wir müssen alles hinterfragen und alles überdenken und
alles neu machen und dann werden dann super Arbeitskreise und Task Forces gebildet, die
natürlich was Neues ausdenken und sobald dann was rauskommt, wo man wirklich was ändern
müsste, wird gesagt, ach nee, wir wissen um unsere Schwächen, das lassen wir jetzt mal
am Sand verlaufen.
Ich habe schon in dieser Firma bei so vielen, in Anführungsstrichen, Innovationsmeetings
und Task Forces und hast du nicht gesehen, mitgemacht und es ist quasi nie was rausgekommen.
Assassin's Creed sagt, ich arbeite deswegen an einem Startup, manchmal stressig, aber
man lernt mega viel aus anderen Bereichen, es ist viel neu, das stimmt wohl, das stimmt
wohl in der Richtung, das einzige, was mich beim Startup stören würde, ist diese Mentalität
und nach dem Motto, du bist 24-7 für die Firma da, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf, ja und
die Bezahlung ist meistens nicht gut und ich behaupte mal, für die meisten Leute hat sich
Startup auch selten finanziell gelohnt, außer du warst halt bei Facebook und hattest Facebook
Aktienup, bevor die an die Börse sind und sowas, aber das ist selten, seltenst.
Ich denke auch, ich denke auch, im Herbst, ich sage euch, es wird im Herbst eh wieder
so laufen, so nach dem Motto, aha, es ist wieder Herbst, es ist wieder Corona am Start
und dann kommt das ganz unvorhergesehen so hoch, wo kommt der Corona auf einmal wieder
her und da muss man dann sehen, am Moment, es war ja noch nie weg, das ist auf einmal
wieder da und es hat im Sommer keine Vorbereitung für getroffen, das wird dann wahrscheinlich
wieder so wie letztes Jahr, so nach dem Motto, ah jetzt müssen wir gucken, dass die Krankenhäuser
nicht überlastet werden, ah jetzt ist Sommer, jetzt ist alles wieder gut, oh es wird Herbst,
uiuiui, jetzt wird es aber langsam wieder gefährlich, ja man hätte sich im Sommer
darauf vorbereiten können, aber YOLO, wer bereitet sich schon im Sommer auf irgendwas
vor, wobei ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass es wieder in diesen Ausmaßen kommt,
ich glaube die Leute machen nicht mehr in diesem Ausmaß mit, wie die letzten Jahre
über, wie die letzten zwei Jahre über, moin Miss Apple 80, das glaube ich nicht, dass
das, dass das noch mal so, noch mal so extrem kommt, beziehungsweise auch so viel Akzeptanz
findet, wie die letzten zwei Jahre, das glaube ich nicht, mir persönlich soll es recht sein,
aber ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, Corona hat ja auch seine Vorteile, nicht die Krankheit
an sich, sondern dass bei vielen deutschen Unternehmen sich mal sowas wie Homeoffice
etabliert hat, was bei dem ganzen Boomer Management bei vielen Läden nie passiert
wäre.
Welchen Internetprovider findest du am wenigsten schlecht, soll ich euch ehrliche Meinung
machen, wenn man von den Mainstream-Internet-Providern ausgeht, ich rede jetzt nicht von Bandbreite,
sondern rein von der Technik her und der Qualität, ihr werdet es mir nicht glauben, aber es ist
tatsächlich die Telekom.
Die Regionalen lasse ich weg, die sind ja überall in Deutschland anders, aber von den Mainstream-Providern
ist es tatsächlich die Telekom, die haben auch genug zum Fremdschämen, aber alle mal
besser als die hier.
Warum ich die hier habe, liegt einzig und allein daran, weil es die Telekom bei mir
noch nicht geschafft hat Glasfaser auszubauen und Vodafone das einzig sinnvolle Angebot
hat was Bandbreite zu Geld angeht, tja das ist halt so ein Arsch, ja ganz einfach, die
müssen ganz ehrlich, ich denke die müssen es fühlen manchmal, die sagen dann auch fühl
ich, das sagt man ja heutzutage so, aber irgendwann müssen die das fühlen, dass die
Leute sich verpissen, wenn das nicht klappt, weil die Sache ist ja die und das muss man
halt auch mal sehen, das finde ich wird zu wenig diskutiert und zu wenig gesagt, dadurch
das Homeoffice mit Corona in größeren Bereichen etabliert hat, ist die Konkurrenz sowohl für
Arbeitnehmer als auch für Arbeitgeber deutschlandweit, wenn nicht sogar international, also sprich
wenn du jemand bist der brauchbar englisch kann und damit keine Probleme hast in der
englischsprachigen Firma zu arbeiten, kannst du auch international suchen und du wirst auch
international genommen, oder zumindest deutschlandweit, weil wenn irgendeine Firma sagt hey wir bieten
Homeoffice an und die sind in München und sagen ja du musst vielleicht mal zu 2 Events
im Jahr nach München fahren, Rest ist 100% Homeoffice, ja super mache ich kein Thema,
besser als 2 mal die Woche mit der Kackbahn nach Frankfurt, mit den Fickern von der Bahn
alter, wenn ich an die schon denken muss, und das ist halt auch die Unternehmen die
das machen haben den Vorteil, die können deutschlandweit suchen, das ist ja auch eventuell Wettbewerbsvorteil
für die, dass die deutschlandweit nach nachfähigen Leuten suchen können, gerade wo sie alle
Schwierigkeiten haben in der Technik Leute zu finden, hört sich an wie ein Lied von
Haftbefehl, die Ficker von der Bahn, ja das sollte, also sowas sollten die mal machen,
da kann er noch irgendwie ein paar Leute Featuren dazu, dann können sie 3 Strophen lang über
die Bahn herziehen, hatte letztens ein Meeting mit einem Kunde, da hat er Head of IT gemeint
damit man LDAPS machen kann, braucht man ja nicht nur der Server, sondern auch der Client
ein Zertifikat, weil sonst könnten die ja nicht richtig verschlüsselt kommunizieren,
ok, die haben keine Ahnung wie asynchrone Verschlüsselung funktioniert oder, wie Public
um, wie heißt das Public Key Infrastructure, alter Abkürzung, das ist denen wahrscheinlich
alles relativ neu, ja Zertifikate von CAS ist ja relativ normal, dass sie lange gehen,
aber Zertifikate die für Domains beispielsweise ausgestellt, Let's Encrypt ist ja auch bloß
3 Monate, ne Moment, 3 Monate gell, das war mal bis zu 6 Monate, jetzt sind es 3 Monate,
ich auch nicht, ich verstehe auch nicht was an Homeoffice Schlimmes, es ist auch nichts
Schlimmes an Homeoffice, ich lasse mir durchaus gefallen, ja es gibt Leute, da klappt das
aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen nicht, die kriegen daheim nichts geschafft, die haben
vielleicht zu viele Ablenkungen daheim, die haben keinen gescheiten Arbeitsplatz daheim,
die machen nichts, wenn der Chef nicht hinter ihnen steht, mag es alles geben, mag es alles
geben, da gibt es bestimmt Leute, die tatsächlich irgendwie halb vereinsamen, wenn sie daheim
sind, alles ok, alles gut, mag es geben, aber deswegen kann man das ja freiwillig machen,
und man sieht ja da, wo es funktioniert und wo es nicht funktioniert, also wo ist das
Problem, ich verstehe es nicht und bei uns wurde einmal Homeoffice technisch angeführt,
ja die Firma hätte, es ist wirklich kein Witz, das haben die uns wirklich versucht
so schmackhaft zu machen, die haben gesagt, ja die Firma hätte ja auch eine gewisse Fürsorgepflicht
für den Arbeitnehmer und es ist teilweise ganz schlimm, was sozial für die Leute passiert,
wenn sie zu lange daheim sind, das war wirklich kein Witz, ein Grund, den sie angeführt haben
gegen Homeoffice und da denke ich mir so Moment, das heißt die Firma will mich beschützen
davor, dass es mir schlecht geht im Homeoffice, ja das ist aber auch nur auf den ersten Blick
valid, weil wenn es danach geht, müssten die mich auch hundertprozentig daheim lassen,
dass ich nicht aus Versehen auf dem Weg zur Arbeit vom Auto erfasst werden kann und die
Chance, dass mir was Schlimmes passiert, ist auf dem Weg in die Arbeit, sicherlich um ein
vielfaches höher wie im Homeoffice, also wenn es denen wirklich um die Fürsorge geht, dann
müssten sie erst recht Homeoffice machen.
Wie gesagt, niemand gibt gerne zu, wenn er keine Ahnung hat oder wenn er Mist erzählt
hat, keine Ahnung haben ist nicht das Problem, aber wenn du wirklich Mist erzählt hast, das
gibt keiner gerne zu, aber es ist jetzt nicht schlimm, also je nachdem, in welcher Runde
das ist, sollte man dann halt auch machen und nicht noch eine halbe Stunde auf das bestehen,
was man vorher gesagt hat.
Was bedeutet denn boomermäßig?
Ahja, wenn deine Führungsetage 50-60 plus ist und halt nur Boomerentscheidungen trifft,
wobei, man kann ja durchaus boomermäßige Entscheidungen auch mit 30 plus treffen, das
ist ja gar kein Problem.
Lieber was mit Holz, ja.
Ich muss sagen, Alkohol im Zug habe ich auch, Maske auf musste ich auch noch, ich mache
das tatsächlich immer noch bei Bedarf, also gerade wenn ich mich irgendwo in die Schlange
stelle, wenn es da wirklich eng ist oder im Supermarkt viel los, dann ziehe ich auch
noch Maske auf, ich gebe mir nicht der Illusion hin, dass ich andere Leute damit beschützen
würde, ist mir auch egal, ob ich andere Leute beschütze, ich habe keinen Bock, dass ich
den Scheiß kriege, reiner Selbstzweck.
Ich bin auch weiterhin auf Jobs suchen, mir geht das so auf die Ketten, dass ich viele
Arbeit nehme, gegen Home Office, ja, habe ich mir jetzt ja auch lange genug darüber
ausgelassen, ja, ist so.
Ich weiß nicht in welchem Bereich du aktiv bist, aber gerade bei so klassischen Bürojobs
oder eben auch Technik-IT-Jobs, wo man vor dem Computer sitzt, es macht keinen Unterschied,
ob du am Rechner auf der Arbeit sitzt oder am Rechner daheim sitzt, es macht keinen Unterschied,
in der Regel ist es sogar besser, wenn du daheim sitzt, ne, ist es nicht, ist es nicht,
asymmetrisch, nicht asynchron, ja, ja, du hast recht, nicht asynchrone Verschlüsselung,
asymmetrisch meine ich, ja, hast recht, Alter, das jetzt haben wir schon, gerade von gesprochen
Leute, ja, das ist bei uns ja auch so, die sind auch am Beschweren die ganze Zeit so
nach dem Motto, oh nein, wir finden keinen, aber Vorzüge bieten, dass die Leute zu uns
wollen, gibt es auch nicht, ja, ist so nice, ich warte noch drauf, dass bei mir endlich
bald Glasfaserausbau von der Telekom ergibt, dann bin ich auch wieder weg von wo da vorn,
auch nicht schlecht, ja, bei uns ist es teilweise so gewesen, also es ist teilweise so, aber
man kann es umgehen, bei uns haben sie gesagt, du darfst in Zukunft, also das ist mittlerweile
wieder aufgeweicht, aber die hatten wirklich die Idee, man soll immer sein Notebook hin
und her schleppen, weil man nur noch mit dem Notebook sich einloggen darf, so nach dem
Motto, wenn ich zwei Tage nach Frankfurt muss, dann soll ich das Notebook jedes mal hin und
her, ich glaube es geht los, dadurch das Notebook die ganze Zeit hin und her und darfst
dann auch nur noch von dort VPN machen und sowas in der Richtung, mittlerweile ist es
deutlich mehr aufgeweicht wieder, ich hab lang genug gemeckert, ich war sogar mal mit
einem Kollegen zusammen auf einer Abteilungsübergreifende Runde und haben gemeckert, wie nervig das
ist und vor allem wie langsam diese ganzen Citrix Vm's sind, die sie uns teilweise für
Remote Arbeit zur Verfügung gestellt haben, ich hab ja gelernt, das heißt gar nicht Citrix,
das heißt eigentlich Citrix und da haben wir lang genug gemeckert und jetzt haben wir
neue 24 Core 64G RAM Linux Vm's bekommen, über die wir uns tunneln können, überall
hin von daheim aus, also quasi wie VPN, nur dass du Azure 2 Factor Authentifizierung davor
hast, ist eigentlich eine coole Lösung muss ich sagen, jetzt benutze ich einfach meine
lokale Linux Vm und tunnle mich über diese Azure Bastion Host Geschichte und gut ist,
2 Factor Authentifizierung gemacht und passt, ja das ist so, ey das könnte durchaus passieren,
ich hab schon teilweise abgelästert auf Twitter und bin dabei über die Straße gelaufen,
zwar meistens nur über die Ampel oder nur über Zebra schreibt, aber man weiß ja nie,
Twitter würde ich sagen, da haben sie Pech gehabt, ja geh doch ins Büro, wenn du ins
Büro willst, wo ist das Problem, kannst du das machen, schon wieder, hattest du nicht
schon mal Corona, ich bringe irgendwie deinen Namen und die Message, hast du nicht schon
mal geschrieben, dass du Corona hast oder ist es noch nicht so lange her und du hast
es einfach die letzten paar Tage schon mal geschrieben, irgendwie bringe ich das gerade
damit in der Verbindung, kann aber auch sein, ich verwechsel, ja gut wenn du vor Ort irgendwo
hinfahren musst um was zu verkaufen, dann ist schwierig mit Homeoffice, es kommt natürlich
auf den Beruf an, das ist schon klar, Grafik und Kommunikationsdesign, bei Grafikdesign
kann ich mir noch vorstellen was man macht, aber wie designt man Kommunikation, das bräuchte
ich wahrscheinlich auch mal, weil die meisten Leute gehen mir so auf den Sack, dass ich
mit denen gar nicht richtig kommunizieren kann, wie ist das eigentlich wenn man als
deutscher Staatsbürger in Schweizer Unternehmen arbeitet, das geht schon, das geht, klar
machen noch ein paar, ich weiß aber nicht ob die Schweizer dir dann so viel bezahlen
wie den schweizern, das ist wahrscheinlich Verhandlungssache, oh Zutrix Admin Paints
Champ, du hast dank meiner Empfehlung den Mikrotik Switch gekauft und wollte ich fragen
ob es dort die Möglichkeit gibt die LEDs auszuschalten, boah, keine Ahnung welchen Switch hast du
gekauft, Router OS Disable LED, weiß nicht ob es das gibt, wenn du Glück hast geht das,
all LEDs off, System LEDs, all LEDs off, das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, mein Switch
steht hinten im Server Raum oder in dieser Abstellkammer, den ich auch schon ein paar
mal gefilmt habe, da stört mich das Geplinke nicht, kannst du auch abkleben ja, ah dann
habe ich dich verwechselt ja, aber ich hoffe du überstehst das gut, so wunderbar, so Chat
geschafft, jetzt müssen wir uns noch etwas weiter bilden Leute, ich lasse mir jetzt mal
Cassandra db in 100 Sekunden erklären, das müssen wir jetzt mal schnell machen, bisschen
Pferde High IQ Fire Chip Videos angucken, erzähl, Sponsort bei was? Data Stacks, Moment ist
das Video Sponsort bei Data Stacks oder ist dieses Cassandra Video Sponsort bei Data Stacks?
Schon sein Video zu Bunn gesehen, ob ich sein Video zu Bunn gesehen habe, weiß ich nicht,
ich habe in den letzten Tagen einige Bunn Videos gesehen, komm mal, bin ich mir nicht
sicher, ob wir das schon mal geguckt haben, ich wette mit euch, den Typ spricht man nicht
so aus, also man spricht, man spricht ihm bestimmt nicht Avishnag Schlagschman aus,
so wie der Typ das ausgesprochen hat, da spricht man wahrscheinlich indisch ganz anders
aus, wenn Apple das macht, dann ist das natürlich genau das Richtige für das nächste Startup,
ok, dann ist das bestimmt im Kubernetes Umfeld saumäßig beliebt, weil da wird ja auch
skaliert was das Zeug hält, also dafür könnte ich mir vorstellen, passt tatsächlich ganz
gut, aber wie gesagt, wir skalieren ja mittlerweile schon diagonal, horizontal skalieren ist out,
also wir skalieren vertikal horizontal quasi dadurch, dass wir diagonal skalieren, machen
wir gleichzeitig horizontales und diagonales skalieren, das geht aber auch nur durch die
ganzen Prime Subs der letzten Jahre, ansonsten wären wir noch gar nicht schlau genug für
das.
Übrigens, bei der Gelegenheit, ich muss mal kurz Pause machen, jetzt Spaß beiseite,
für alle die mit diesem Begriff skalieren nichts anfangen können, ich versuche das
mal anhand von so aktueller Cloud Technologie zu erklären, also stellt euch mal vor, ihr
habt einen Service, den ihr anbietet, der ziemlich stark schwankende Nutzerzahlen hat,
das kann alles möglich sein, zum Beispiel einen Shop, die Leute kaufen halt nachts
um 5 weniger ein als abends um 15 Uhr, oder was weiß ich, PewDiePie hat euch geschoutoutet
und jetzt gehen alle auf euren Shop, also denkt mal, ihr habt einen Webservice, oder
ihr nehmt einen Webservice, der ziemlich stark fluktuierende Nutzerzahlen hat, so und jetzt
gibt es immer die Sache mit horizontal und vertikal skalieren, also in der Regel ist
damit folgendes gemeint, du hast einen Cluster, sag mal Vmware oder ein Kubernetes Cluster,
dort läuft deine Anwendung drauf, so und standardmäßig hast du 5 Hardware oder 3 Hardware Kisten
und darüber verteilt hast du 10 mal deine Anwendung parallel laufen, so und jetzt ist
es Cyber Monday oder was auch immer, Black Friday und was es da alles gibt und die Leute
stürmen dir deinen Job, äh deinen Shop und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kannst du, wie schaffst
du es mehr User abzufackeln als mit den Gegebenheiten, wie sie aktuell sind, jetzt kannst du vertikal
und horizontal skalieren, das heißt vertikal skalieren bedeutet in der Regel, du fährst
mehr Instanzen von deiner Anwendung hoch, also sprich, du hast aktuell ein Cluster aus
3x Backend Hardware und darauf läuft 10x deine Anwendung, die Dinger sind nicht wirklich
ausgelastet und jetzt startest du noch 10x deine Anwendung parallel und dann läuft deine
Anwendung 20x und du kannst mehr User ab, so, das ist vertikal skaliert, jetzt hast du
irgendwann vielleicht mal das Problem, naja, meine eigentliche drunter liegende Hardware
kommt langsam auch an die Grenzen und jetzt kannst du horizontal skalieren, kann übrigens
auch sein, dass es genau umgedreht ist zu dem, was ich jetzt erzähle, wenn ich mir recht
überlege und jetzt kannst du horizontal skalieren, du kannst noch eine vierte Hardwarekiste dabei
stellen und dann kannst du weiter Instanzen drauf laufen lassen, also wenn du neue Hardware
Cluster, wenn du Cluster erweiterst, dann ist das in der Regel quasi horizontal skaliert
und wenn du quasi die Anwendung weiter parallelisierst, dann ist das dann meistens vertikal skaliert.
Ja, das macht man dann oftmals so mit Container, mit so Containerbildchen, ja, also sprich,
wenn du, du hast deine Anwendung quasi dreimal laufen und wenn du jetzt vertikal skalierst,
dann machst du halt hier noch einen weiteren Container drauf, so, Container drauf, Container
drauf, Container drauf, so, also sprich, du skalierst, wenn du so willst vertikal und
wenn du jetzt hier noch einen neuen Node dabei baust, um dort, dort das gleiche zu machen,
so, dann hast du horizontal skaliert oder umgedreht, ich bin mir grad nicht ganz sicher,
aber ich glaube, das stimmt, was ich sag, ja, warum du das nicht machen solltest, ganz
einfach, weil du vielleicht mehrere Anwendungen hast, also es heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig,
dass du nur eine Anwendung betreibst, die, die Hardware komplett auslasten soll oder
so und das andere ist, der, ich glaube, es kann auch sein, dass es umgedreht ist, der
wahrscheinlichere Fall ist, dass die Hardware gar nicht bei dir im Rechenzentrum steht,
sondern du irgendwelche Cloud-Services dafür verwendest, der klassische Fall wäre natürlich
VMs, dann ist es ähnlich wie bei eigener Hardware, aber spätestens, wenn du irgendwelche
so SS-Service-Geschichten verwendest, irgendwelche Functions oder sonst was, dann bezahlst du
ja direkt das, was du verwendest und dann macht es natürlich mehr Sinn, aber es macht
bei VMs auch Sinn, vielleicht kannst du nämlich die VM auf einem Triple-Core lassen und musst
nicht das Zehnfache bezahlen für einen 16-Kerner oder sowas, also das ist immer Frage des
Geldes letztendlich, was man machen will und gerade zu Cloud-Zeiten aktuell ist es natürlich
sinnig zu sagen, ich kann quasi alles runterfahren und ausschalten, möglicherweise sogar löschen
in so Nebenzeiten und lass dann über irgendwelche Automatisierungs-Tools oder eben über Cluster-Erweiterung,
wenn man irgendwelche Kubernetes-Sachen hat, das wieder erweitern, wenn mehr User kommen.
Wenn es natürlich wirklich deine dedizierte Hardware ist, die sonst nichts anderes macht,
dann ist egal, dann musst du dann aber auch gar nicht mit irgendwelchen komischen Containern
und Clustern anfangen, da haust du deine Anwendung einfach da drauf und lässt die halt
parallel ihre Requests machen, wie sie lustig ist, dann kann sie halt 24 Kerne, 96 Gigabyte
RAM verwenden, wenn es eh deine Hardware ist, dann ist egal, die hast du ja schon bezahlt.
Was hältst du von Web3, das ist mir zu Krypto-NFT-lastig, es interessiert mich nicht großartig.
Einfach Stateless programmieren, ja, nee, nee, Moment, einfach Hardcoded programmieren,
weil, überlegt euch mal, solange das Programm kein Input mehr braucht und jeglicher State
Hardcoded ist, hast du ein fehlerfreies Programm, es kann nix mehr kaputt gehen.
Du hast dann zwar ein Programm, was 30 Terabyte groß ist und 50 Milliarden Ifs enthält, aber
du hast alles einprogrammiert.
Geht natürlich in der Praxis nicht, ja.
So, lass das Video fertig gucken.
Das kommt drauf an, du hast ein gutes Thema angesprochen, ganz ehrlich, Datenbanken skalieren
oder Datenbank-Clustern sind eines der advanceden Sachen überhaupt, da gibt es unterschiedliche
Strategien, es gibt zum Beispiel die Strategie, das ist die erste, die mir jetzt einfällt,
dass du den Cluster erweiterst, beziehungsweise mehrere Read-Instanzen hast, also dass du
quasi parallel lesen kannst, aber nur eine Datenbank kann schreiben, weil das ist ein
bisschen wie bei Multithreading, wenn du nur an einer Stelle schreibst, aber an mehreren
Stellen liest, ist es in der Regel Threadsafe, ohne dass du irgendwelche Logs brauchst.
Und nachdem es bei Datenbanken, gerade wenn es, ja, so Web-Anwendungen sind, zu 90% Datenbank
read sind, dann kannst du mehrere Datenbanken hinstellen, read only und nur eine Master-Datenbank
kann schreiben.
Das skaliert dann auch relativ gut, lässt sich auch relativ easy erweitern und du hast
nicht die Probleme von parallelen Schreibzugriffen, aber ja, Datenbanken skalieren ist tatsächlich
eines der feifertigsten Sachen, die es gibt, aber vielleicht kommt ja noch was zu jetzt
hier, bei dem Video, also ist es quasi eine NoSQL mit SQL, oder wie, was?
Siehst du, da sind wir wieder beim Thema, da ist es unglaublich wichtig, dass du die
Sachen halt wirklich auch nur so beanspruchslos brauchst, weil ansonsten bezahlst du unnötig
Geld.
Aha, okay, verstehe.
Ja, es sieht verdächtig nach SQL aus.
Ah ja, alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, KassandraDB, das war's für heute, bis zum
nächsten Mal.
Also, Soap haben wir glücklicherweise, glaube ich, so gut wie gar nicht mehr, ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass irgendwelche Oldschool-Java-Services vielleicht noch Soap machen bei uns, aber dafür
bin ich zu wenig drin, was diese Anwendung angeht, ich könnte mir vorstellen, manche
machen vielleicht noch Soap, aber die meisten dürften Jason-Request sein.
Ja, anscheinend hat KassandraDB dann auch keine Joints, wobei man natürlich immer Joints
von Hand machen kann, gehe ich mal ganz stark von aus, also Software-seitige Joints gehen
ja logischerweise immer, die sind dann wahrscheinlich nicht so geschwind, also nach dem Motto, ich
frage halt einfach zwei Datensätze ab und dann gucke ich, wo es übereinstimmt, das kann
ich machen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es effizienter ist, aber ganz im Ernst, je nachdem
wie komplex das ist, also NoSQL hat schon ein paar coole Sachen, gerade so nach dem Motto
einfach Jason direkt als String rein pumpen und so, das ist schon nice, je nachdem wie
komplex das ist, hat es dann wieder seine Vor- und Nachteile, deswegen mag ich ja auch
Postgres, Postgres hat ja auch wunderbaren Jason-Support, Postgres ist ja das beste,
Join ist doch auch Software-seitig, naja gut, wenn du es so willst, ist alles Software-seitig,
weil die Datenbank ja auch in irgendeiner Sprache programmiert ist, also die Datenbank
läuft auf deiner Hardware genauso wie dein Programm, ja also wenn du es so willst, ist
das alles Software-seitig, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Datenbank halt besser weiß, was sie
intern macht, als du wahrscheinlich, ja so gesehen ist alles, ist auch Stream gucken
ist auch Software-seitig, aber du hast recht, jaja klar ist schon so, Drag, was Drag, das
klingt, ach ach Dragon, nicht, nicht, das ist C++ ja, das kenne ich, das ist C++, ich
kenne das aber nur aus dem Benchmark, weil es da gut abgeschnitten hat, ich würde es
nicht benutzen, ja bei SAP wundert mich nichts mehr, SAP ist das, bei SAP erwartest du doch
eigentlich schon, dass es Oldschool-shit ist oder, nutzt du oder hast du schon mal Rider
probiert, also man könnte sagen, ich benutze Rider öfters mal, ja
ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen, da hat jemand versucht Multithreaded mit
Workers zu machen in Node.js, das war ganz wirra Shit, aber gehen tut's, wir haben auch
letztens Multithreading gemacht, ein bisschen, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, WebAssembly
C++ war auch ein bisschen Multithreaded am Start, aber halt auch wieder abfuck, ok was,
Rektor an einer Gemeinschaftsschule, das Gehalt als Schule, ey Leute, ich hätte so
keinen Bock drauf in der Schule zu arbeiten, so absolut überhaupt gar keinen Bock, es
gibt glaube ich, sie könnten mir, so viel Geld könnten die mir gar nicht bezahlen,
dass ich in der Schule arbeiten würde, Darkwixi, wie dankeschön, 25 Monate Hyper-Subscription,
Massive-Subs, ja nice, Rektor in einer Schule, ich weiß nicht, gucken wir das heute noch
oder gucken wir es am Sonntag, weil eigentlich wisst ihr was jetzt ist oder, eigentlich ist
jetzt 22 Uhr und 22 Uhr ist Bumer müde, schon spät, wundert mich nicht, noch kurz Ban
angucken, wollen wir uns noch Ban angucken Leute, weil ihr es seid, wir gucken uns noch
Ban an, ja wir wissen ja alle, dass er sich über JavaScript, Moment, das haben wir schon
gesehen, das haben wir schon gesehen, das haben wir schon gesehen, ich kenne das Video, das
haben wir schon gesehen, egal, wir können es trotzdem noch durchlaufen lassen, ich meine
Albert Einstein hat auch gesagt C++ ist kacke, ja, also allgemein bekannt, ja, ja, also allgemein
bekannt, wisst ihr was ein bisschen peinlich ist, dass die Go-Performance bei SQLite sackt,
also sackt, ja, also im Vergleich, im Vergleich zu anderen Sprachen, ich bin jetzt zwar nicht
so der richtige Go, wie nennen sich die Go-Programmierer, haben die Go-Programmierer auch irgendwie
so eine schöne Bezeichnung, ja, also bei Rust nennen die sich ja irgendwie Rust Crustations,
nee Goffer ist das, ist doch das Maskottchen, ja, also ich bin jetzt nicht der größte Go-Fan,
ich habe ein paar kleinere Sachen in Go schon gemacht und ich kann es lesen, ich kann es
schreiben, ja, ich bin jetzt nicht so super krasser Go-Fan, aber was mich bei Go immer
ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat und immer noch abschreckt ist, dass sobald du Interop machen
musst mit anderen Programmiersprachen, dass es dann eklig wird, Go ist hauptsächlich
darauf ausgelegt, Go mit Go zu verwenden, also sobald du beispielsweise SQLite verwenden
willst, weil SQLite halt C ist, d.h. du brauchst C-Aufrufe hin und her, ist Go sicherlich
noch schneller als so was wie Python und Ruby, da kann ich euch garantieren, aber das könnte
schon durchaus schneller sein, sie haben ja die letzten Sprache über, die letzten Releases
der Sprache viel dran optimiert, aber es hat immer noch seine Probleme bei C-Interop und
was noch schlimmer ist, also Go zu C geht noch halbwegs von der Performance, was ganz
schlimm ist, ist C zu Go, also wenn du beispielsweise von Go C aufrufst und dort dann ein Callback
übergibst, den du später aufrufst, von C nach Go Callen, das ist glaube ich 150 mal
langsamer als ein Go Function Call, warum man eigentlich in Go programmieren sollte, weil
Go ziemlich verbreitet ist im Cloud Ökosystem, ist eine ziemlich gute Einsteigerprogrammiersprache,
relativ viele Libraries hat, relativ einfach zu lernen, ist ziemlich gut für Multi-Splitting
bzw. so nebenläufige Sachen, hat schon seine Vorteile, ich persönlich muss sagen, warum
ich nicht mehr in Go mache, achja, Go hat auch jegliches, na so fast as fuck, Go ist
ordentlich schnell, Go spielt in ähnlichen Regionen wie so die meisten anderen Dinge,
also der Unterschied zwischen C-Sharp und Go ist jetzt nicht groß, JavaScript ist ein
bisschen langsamer, aber jetzt auch nicht so viel langsamer, also Go ist schnell, aber
wenn du ein ordentliches C++ C Ding Rust hast, ist es nochmal eine Ecke schneller, wohlgemerkt,
wir reden hier von V8 JavaScript und halt auch nur im Fall, wo das das schön optimieren
kann, Standard Library ist gut, ja und eine Sache, wo Go richtig gut ist, die haben halt
jegliche Deployment-Probleme gelöst, dadurch, dass Go Binaries alle statisch sind, sind
die zwar ein bisschen fetter, also wir reden jetzt hier beispielsweise, sagen wir mal,
ein C-Binary wäre, ein Hello World C-Binary wäre, keine Ahnung, 450 Byte oder so und
selbst wahrscheinlich statisch gelingt noch relativ klein, dann ist ein Go-Binary, ein
gleiches Go-Binary wahrscheinlich 10 MB oder so groß, aus dem Kopf, ich weiß es nicht,
wie es genau ist, aber so ungefähr von den Größenordnungen, aber Speicherplatz juckt
ich ja heute keinen mehr und dadurch, dass Go alles statisch reinlinkt, also dass die
statische Binaries bauen, haben die jegliche Deployment-Probleme gelöst, du kompilierst
ein Go-Programm, kopierst es auf deinen Server und egal, wie alt oder wie neu der ist, Linux,
ja, läuft einfach, Go Binaries sind abwärts kompatibel zu kernel 2639, das muss man sich
mal vorstellen, 2639, Alter 2639 kernel released, das war 2008 oder so oder 2011, ja, also Go-Programme
sind rückwärts kompatibel zu jedem Linux der letzten 11 Jahre und sind auch vorwärts
kompatibel, wenn man es so will, zu allen erscheinenden Linux-Versionen, also Go-Programme
sind wirklich in der Beziehung, was Deployment angeht und wie einfach das ist, das beste,
was es gibt, also da ist Go nicht schlecht, warum ich wenig in Go mache ist, ich mag die
Go-Syntax nicht, also nicht das Schlüsselwort Go, was ich nicht mag, sondern ich mag einiges
an der Go-Syntax nicht, auf der einen Seite ist Go relativ üppig, ja, also was Standard-Library
angeht, du kannst auf drei verschiedene Varianten, Variablen definieren und sowas, aber auf der
anderen Seite sagen sie immer noch, hey, mach mal gefälligst eine Schleife, wenn du einen
Array filtern willst oder, ne, wir haben keine dynamischen Listen, wir machen das mit Delete
und Add über so komische Magic-Methoden oder habt ihr mal in Go gecheckt, ob ein Dictionary
in Key enthält, hier, Go has Key, ja, guckt euch das mal an, wahrscheinlich Leute, die
nix anderes als Go machen, finden das wahrscheinlich hübsch, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich
finde das ziemlich pains-champ, wenn ich sowas sehe, das hier ist der Error-Code, also das
ist hier der Check, ob es gefunden hat, also, ich weiß ja nicht, ich mag die Go-Syntax
nicht sonderlich, ich hoffe, dass sich Go dadurch, dass sie jetzt Generics haben, ein
bisschen dahin entwickeln wird, dass Leute sich mal erbarmen und so ein paar gescheite,
jetzt sollten wir es Funktionale Libraries nennen, ne, so ein paar gescheite Libraries
programmieren, dass du auch mal Listen ordentlich filtern kannst und sowas, das konntest du
ja vorher in Go nie bauen, weil du eben keine Typen dafür angeben konntest, du konntest
nur alles mit Interface machen, was ja quasi sowas wie Object ist in C Sharp, das war auch
nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss und jetzt mit Generics ist das hoffentlich so, dass
es da ein paar gescheite Libraries geben wird, dass man in Go auch mal sowas machen kann
wie Array, Punkt, Filter und dann sagen alle Elemente größer 2, aktuell musst du in Go
nämlich eine Schleife dafür machen, das finde ich ziemlich doof. Man muss echt sagen, ich
habe schon ein paar Webcasts und Vorträge gesehen von V8 Entwicklern von Google, wo
sie erklärt haben, was sie an Optimierung in V8 gemacht haben und Leute ich sage euch,
das ist absolut Next Level 5 Head Shit, ich hatte wirklich meine Schwierigkeiten teilweise
da mit zu kommen, was die da genau erzählen, Baba hat Subscribed, Dankeschön für den Sub,
das ist wirklich ziemlich sick, da hatte einer ein Beispiel in einem Talk, Konferenz Talk
V8, wo sie gezeigt haben, dass quasi wenn du, nee muss ich anders sagen, sie haben gezeigt
wie V8 quasi Optimierung prediktet, ob man was optimieren kann und wie man es am besten
optimiert und dass sich V8 manchmal vertut, da hat er ein Beispiel gezeigt, da hatte er
eine Vorschleife in JavaScript und er hat die Abbruchbedingungen nicht direkt in die
Schleife geschrieben, sondern irgendwie über eine Variable eingelesen und das hat dann dazu
geführt, dass die Schleife eben nicht optimiert werden konnte und dann hat er gesagt, ja und
wenn wir jetzt die Bedingungen so schreiben, dass V8 es versteht, ist die Schleife 150
mal schneller gewesen und so was und da wären sie gerade dabei, das zu erkennen und diesen
Fall zu optimieren, dass es immer 150% schneller läuft und so was, also die V8 Leute sind wirklich
Next Level Big Brain, High IQ, da gibt es nichts, ich meine man muss sich mal überlegen,
mit V8 im günstigen Fall ist V8 ähnlich schnell wie C++, nicht so schnell, gebe ich zu, aber
ähnlich schnell, wir reden jetzt, also wenn ich sage ähnlich schnell, dann meine ich
damit, es kann durchaus 2-3 mal langsamer sein, aber nicht 150 mal langsamer, also mit den
passenden Optimierungen und wenn du dein JavaScript, wenn V8 dein JavaScript ordentlich optimieren
kann, muss man sich mal vorstellen, JavaScript im Browser läuft ähnlich schnell wie C++,
ja ok 3-4 mal langsamer, aber trotzdem, saumäßig schnell, nicht 150 mal langsamer.
Der so complete JavaScript halt ist, ich meine, not a number ist in JavaScript auch nicht
a number, das wissen wir ja, und übrigens wisst ihr woran mich das Ding mega erinnert,
ich glaube ich habe es das letzte Mal schon gesagt, Overwatch Pachimari oder so, guckt
euch mal dieses Overwatch Plush Ding an, das sieht schon, ich meine guckt mal, es hat gewisse
Ähnlichkeiten, oder müsst ihr zugeben?
Ok, auf gehts, Chainlore, PokiW-Check, siehst du, du bist doch nicht mal Sub.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich kenne nichts, was in SICK programmiert wäre, außer BUN.
Mir war die Existenz dieser Programmiersprache bis dahin nicht wirklich präsent im Kopf.
Ja gut, Webpack ist ja auch eines der schlimmsten Ausgeburten der Hölle, die es gibt, mag
jemand Webpack?
Gibt es jemand, der Webpack gerne benutzt und konfiguriert, vor allem, wir sind eigentlich
mittlerweile, wir sind eigentlich mittlerweile der NPM Support in Deno, am Anfang haben sie
ja in Deno gesagt, nee nee nee, NPM ist doof, NPM wollen wir nicht, und ich habe damals
auch schon manchmal hier im Stream gesagt, das was mich ja von Deno ein bisschen abschreckt
ist, dass die kein NPM haben, ich meine NPM ist abfuck extrem, gerade die ganzen Sicherheitsprobleme
der letzten Monate und Jahre, keine Frage, aber eine ordentliche Package, Registry oder
Package Database ist schon was sehr Sinnvolles und hat nicht umsonst jede moderne Programmiersprache
der letzten 15 Jahre, außer C++, aber C++ ist ja auch nicht modern, die tun bloß so,
deswegen habe ich bei Deno nicht verstanden und mittlerweile ist es ja in Deno so, dass
die wohl NPM Support eingebaut haben, aber wohl nicht alles unterstützen, auch irgendwie
merkwürdig jetzt, weil es wollten ja erst nicht, ja C++ hat leider 15 Package Manager,
ich weiß, aber du brauchst sowas offiziell in die Sprache integriert, sonst wird es sich
nicht durchsetzen, ich weiß es gibt ein paar Package Manager, die das versucht haben, aber
es ist nicht so, wie Node.js, wo man.env in jedes Projekt installieren muss, das größte
Problem an C++, was die auch nie los werden sind, Header Files, das ist einfach für sowas
schlechter geeignet als ein ordentliches Modulsystem und ja, ich weiß, C++ hat mittlerweile Module,
mal gucken, wann es breitflächigen Compiler Support dafür gibt und mal gucken, wann die
wichtigsten Projekte das auch als Modul anbieten und keine Header Files mehr, also ich glaube,
wir sehen uns dann so in 15 Jahren oder so vielleicht, Moment, ich habe gestern gelesen
an das Geheimtipp, ein neues Management-Busword, wenn etwas schnell ist, sagt man heutzutage
nicht mehr, es ist schnell oder es ist next level oder es ist flott oder so, man sagt,
es ist turbocharged, ich habe letztes gelesen, neues Manager-Busword, also wenn ihr Manager
Speak mit eurem Manager reden wollt, dann sagt ihr, dass etwas turbocharged ist, also
wenn ihr was beispielsweise verbessert habt und sagt, das ist jetzt doppelt schnell,
hast du gesagt, ich habe die User Experience turbocharged, dann sagt er, boah, krasser
Typ.
Nice, ja, der macht echt gute Videos, aber das haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Du hast das UI agilisiert, nice, das User Interface, oder besser gesagt, das User ist
ja nicht allein, das User Interface ist die User Experience, ist es ja, das User Interface
ist ja nur ein Teil der User Experience, ne, das schaue ich jetzt nicht, ich gehe jetzt
ins Bett, Leute, ich turbocharge jetzt ins Bett sozusagen, am Wochenende wahrscheinlich
sponsored Hetzer Stream, wenn wir uns bis dahin einig sind, wenn nicht nächste Woche
und da gibt es auch einen neuen Code mit 20€ Startguthaben.
Danke für die ganzen Subs, die es heute gegeben hat, Leute, spontaner Stream, nicht vorhandener
Keiner Stream, wir sehen uns bis dahin, machts gut, Cyo.